DEBI CABRERA: Data by any other
name would still be as sweet,
but how dost thou process
and transform data?
AKA, data is very
powerful, but how do you
process and transform it?
Join me as I show
you with Apache Beam.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
In this video, we'll walk
through a demonstration
of Apache Beam.
If you haven't seen
the last video,
I recommend checking it out
since we talk about some
of the key concepts that
make up a pipeline in Beam.
There's a link in
the description.
In this example, we'll
walk through using
Beam to count the words from
Shakespeare's "King Lear."
And we'll show what it looks
like to use Google Cloud
Dataflow as a runner.
This is a great starting
example of a batch data job,
since we're working with
a file which is bounded,
as opposed to streaming data
processing, which is typically
unbounded because there's
no fixed start or end.
Let's take a look at what
our batch data pipeline does.
Here's what the
pipeline looks like.
The first thing we'll do is read
from a text file that contains
the entire copy of "King Lear."
After that, we'll use
transforms to split
each line into
individual words, count
the instances of each word,
and output the results.
Each PTransform takes
a PCollection as input
and sends one out as output
so we can chain together
the transforms.
So first things first.
We can check out the input file.
This is just a short
snippet, but the entire book
is included in the text
file we'll be using.
Of course, there's lots
of words in this book.
So let's get started
counting them.
In this example,
we're using Python.
So the first step is to install
the Apache Beam files we need.
After that, we can run
the word count example
and specify the input
and output files.
Since we're not
specifying a runner,
the default is to use the direct
runner, which runs the pipeline
right on your machine.
If you're just getting
started or looking to debug,
the direct runner
is likely how you'll
want to run your pipelines.
After all, Beam is designed so
you can run the same pipeline
code on different runners.
Your local environment might
be fine for "King Lear,"
but what if your
batch data job was
counting all of the words
for an entire library's
worth of books?
In that case, we can just
provide a few more options
to the code and use Google Cloud
Dataflow as the runner instead.
The input file comes from
a publicly-accessible Cloud
Storage file, while the
output will be a Cloud Storage
bucket that I created earlier.
We're also specifying
to use the Dataflow
runner and some other details,
like which Google Cloud project
this runs on.
Once we run this
command, the job
will be created and Dataflow
and start processing.
Let's take a closer
look at the code.
The core part of the
code happens here,
after the pipeline has been
set up with these options
that we provided.
This first part of the
pipeline reads the text
from the input file and creates
a PCollection of each line
from the file.
From here, we use read transform
from the line's PCollection.
The first transform to split
the line into separate words,
one transform to turn each
word into a single kind of one,
and another transform
to group and sum
all of the words and counts.
The pipe operator
for Beam and Python
is short for applying a
transformation to a collection.
So with this short
block of code,
we're able to chain the
PTransforms together
by using the output PCollection
of the previous transform
as the input.
ParDo is a transformation
that takes each element
from the input PCollection
and performs a function on it.
In this case, we
have a custom regex
that simply looks for groups
of non-white space characters
and splits each line
of text into words.
The final transform formats the
text using a custom function
and finally outputs
it to the bucket.
This is a fairly
straightforward pipeline,
so these few transforms
are all we need.
While this is running, let's
take a look at Dataflow
in the Cloud Console.
You can see the
status of the job
in each step of the pipeline.
The name for each transform
step comes from the code.
You can also click on each
step to see more details.
Over time, the
interface will update,
and pretty soon, the
pipeline will be complete.
Beam is designed
to run pipelines
with parallel processing.
So if you're working on a large
batch or a streaming data job,
the pipeline still
looks the same.
Thankfully, Google
Cloud and Dataflow
will handle all the
infrastructure details for us.
So with just that
short bit of code,
we've been able to get a
count of all the words.
Now, if we take a look
at the output file,
we can see the count of all
the words in "King Lear."
However, you might notice that
there are two separate counts
for the word "king."
That's because we didn't
take capitalization
to account when grouping.
The easiest way
to fix that would
be to add another PTransform.
After we split the
sentence up into words,
we could simply
lowercase all the words
and then pass that PCollection
over to the group and sum
transformation.
Apache Beam is a powerful
tool to help you process data.
And the word count
example we just went over
is a simple way to get started.
There's some links
in the documentation
with more information, including
an interactive tutorial you
can take right in the
Google Cloud Console.
Thanks for watching.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]